herzlich willkommen ja egal wohin man
derzeit blickt ob nach italien in die
usa oder die türkei überall geben
populisten den ton an politiker die im
namen des volkes gegen eliten und
etablierte institutionen kämpfen warum
sind diese populisten so erfolgreich und
sind vielleicht ziehe die wahren
demokraten tram erdogan le pen blocher
weidl tsipras grillo chávez orban und
putin populisten prägen seit einigen
jahren die politischen bühnen der welt
doch was bedeutet der begriff populismus
eigentlich genau
und wieso passt er auch auf politiker
die teils konträre meinungen vertreten
wir fragen einen der es wissen sollte
der woche sieht der populist weiß nicht
nur seit märz aber sie sind also
wenigsten werden herr müller sie sind
professor für politische theorie und
princeton und haben sich eingehend mit
dem phänomen des populismus befasst ist
in christoph blocher ein populist ich
mache ihnen ein begriffs angebot wie
wird dieses phänomen populismus zu
fassen kriegen könnten
und mit verlaub überlasse ist dann den
schweizerinnen und schweizern zu
entscheiden ob das passt oder nicht denn
ich nehme an dass diese mehr über die
schweiz und herrn blocher wissen als ich
es wird ja häufig gesagt dass all
diejenigen die eliten kritisieren
deswegen schon automatisch vielleicht
viele demokratie irgendwie gefährliche
populisten sind so einfach ist es nicht
im gegenteil den mächtigen auf die
finger zu schauen kann durchaus ein
zeichen guten demokratischen engagement
seitens der bürger sein
es stimmt natürlich dass populisten wenn
sie in der opposition sind immer die
regierung ergo die mächtigen kritisieren
vor allem tun sie aber 1 sie behaupten
stets dass sie und nur sie das
repräsentieren was man listen häufig als
die schweigende mehrheit oder auch als
das wahre volk
dann wird das heißt dass sie dann auch
behaupten dass alle anderen wettbewerber
um die macht grundsätzlich legitim sein
da wird man auch sofort sehr persönlich
und hoch moralisch die sind alle grob
die arbeiten nicht was folgt die
arbeiten nur für sich selber etc und
weniger offensichtlich all diejenigen im
volke selbst all die bürger welche die
letztlich symbolische konstruktion des
vermeintlich wahren volkes seitens der
populisten nicht teilen und ergo die
populisten dann auch politisch nicht
unterstützen bei all diesen bürgern darf
und dann erst mal in frage stellen ob
sie wirklich dazugehören
lange rede kurzer sinn das entscheidende
bei den populisten ist nicht das anti
elitäre das entscheidende ist der anti
pluralismus diese vorstellung eines
homogenen volkes für das nur sie die
populisten sprechen sie würden nach
sagen dieser anspruch der joachim bordt
selbst drin steckt ist das populus
sozusagen das volk zu vertreten weil das
ist ja etwas das irgendwie eigentlich
ist das selbstverständlich jedes
demokratischen politiker sein sollte
nämlich das volk zu vertreten aber die
populisten geben gehen da aus ihrer
sicht einen schritt zu weit
natürlich sollte jeder politiker den
anspruch haben das volk zu vertreten
es ist auch nicht irgendwie illegitim
oder an richtig zu sagen meine
vorstellung des volkes ist die folgende
ich möchte dass unser land die schweiz
meinetwegen sich in diese richtung
bewegt leute folgt mir völlig normal in
der demokratie was nicht normal ist ist
dass man jedem der mit einem nicht
übereinstimmt sofort vorwirft im falle
von donald trump unamerikanisch zu sein
oder vielleicht ein paar der schweiz und
schweizerischen zu sein
das ist wieder diese anti pluralismus
und außerdem ich würde nicht behaupten
dass sie das alle machen aber sehr
häufig zum populisten die eine wahl
verlieren
und ja in gewisser weise kann sofort ein
kardiologisches problem haben denn wie
kann es denn sein dass sie die einzig
wahren vertreter des volkes sind
aber das volk hat ihnen kein mandat
erteilt das kann ja eigentlich gar nicht
sein
dann kommt es sehr häufig wie gesagt
nicht immer vor dass populisten sagen
moment diese berühmte formel von der
schweigenden mehrheit
schauen wir uns die vielleicht doch noch
mal
genauer an vielleicht wollte das volk ja
gar nicht schweigen denn wenn es nicht
geschwiegen hätte wären wir ja immer
schon an der macht logischerweise also
vielleicht hat irgendjemand das volk
nicht reden lassen wollen oder zum
schweigen gebracht
deswegen gibt es sehr viele beispiele
von populisten die nach einer verlorenen
wahl sofort um es jetzt sehr hart und
deutlich zu sagen eine
verschwörungstheorie los hier dann sagen
wir haben nur deswegen verloren weil die
eliten mal wieder irgendetwas
gemauschelt haben und das volk von dem
wir ja angeblich die einzigen vertreter
sind irgendwie außen vor gehalten und
das ist wiederum in gewisser weise auch
ein zeichen dafür dass auch populisten
wenn sie gar nicht an die regierung
kommen unter umständen einer
demokratischen politischen kultur einen
schaden zufügen der sie sagen ihren
anhängern ja nichts anderes als dass
diese institution unser wahlsystem das
ist alles nur fassade dahinter geht
irgendwie immer irgendwie was ganz
anderes vor
was ich bemühe mich sofort hinzuzufügen
nicht heißen soll dass wir diese
institution nicht kritisieren dürfen
natürlich dürfen wir das was wir nicht
dürfen ist zu sagen wie soll man sich
populisten tun weil ich die wahl nicht
gewonnen habe ist unser system irgendwie
muss das ist keine demokratische
einstellung
das sieht man häufig und populisten zum
beispiel auch bei tom trump jetzt
interessiert mich diese definition die
sie geben sozusagen dieses diesen
moralischen alleinvertretungsanspruch
nennen sie das also dass die hinstellen
und sagen wir und nur wir repräsentieren
oder vertreten das volk das ist ziemlich
formal würde ich mal sagen weil mit
populismus
damit verbindet man ja auch doch auch
politiker die irgendwie eine einfache
wortwahl haben dem volk nach dem munde
reden angeblich emotionen bewirtschaften
die ängste und ressentiments die
einfache lösung für komplexe probleme
vorschlagen die provozieren
die stark auf die person spielen und so
was ist das was machen sie auch mit
diesem mit diesen merkmalen die man die
wir gemeinhin mit dem populismus
verbinden ich versuche die eigentlich
beiseite zu lassen denn ich fürchte dass
es da sehr schnell willkürlich
wer entscheidet denn genau ob jetzt eine
gewisse politik vorstellung zu
vereinfachend oder wie es ja bei der
wirtschaftswissenschaftler häufig heißt
irgendwie unverantwortlich ist ich will
damit nicht behaupten dass das alles so
wie beliebig ist aber würde sagen was
sie sind inhaltlichen fragen sofort
darauf zu schließen
populismus sei so eine art ideologie
oder gar philosophie die man dann in
diesem spezifischen inhalten festmachen
könnte das scheint mir ein irrweg zu
sein
es geht ja letztendlich immer um einen
ganz spezifischen bezug zum volk ergo
auch der name populismus da muss ja
irgendwie das volk auf eine ganz
spezifische weise vorkommen
und deswegen ist es auch keine frage von
rechts oder links es gibt ja bisweilen
auf der linken diese meinung des
populismus im schlechten sinne kann es
gar nicht geben denn die linke ist ja
immer gut ergo kann es so was wie links
populismus nicht geben aber jemand der
eben schon vorkam ist natürlich ein
paradebeispiel für linken populismus
nämlich hugo chavez wo ja ab einem
gewissen zeitpunkt klar war
man konnte nicht wirklich auf legitime
weise anderer ansicht sein als scharfes
ohne sofort den vorwurf zu hören zu
bekommen ihr werdet aber nur vom
imperialismus bezahlt oder ihr verratet
dieses bolivianische projekt ihr sagt
gar keine echten bürger in diesem
sozialistischen projekt für das
einundzwanzigste jahrhundert da auch
wieder dieses für mich entscheidende
merkmal von anti pluralismus wo man dem
gegner nicht nur sagt gut wie ist
anderer meinung
natürlich gibt es mehr demokratie
ständig konflikt ist ja auch völlig
normal aber sozusagen von vornherein zu
sein der gegner hat überhaupt keine
legitimität und gehört nicht dazu und
viele argumente brauchen wir uns auch
nicht zu interessieren denn die
kündigung von immer von vornherein schon
sagen die werden von außen gesteuert
wenn sie gegen uns sind werden von
amerika bezahlen jetzt als wenig
spannend dass sie auch sagen also es
gibt den links populismus ja was als
beispiel und auch da müssten sie
eigentlich sagen ihrer definition
folgend dass die eine idee haben von
einem homogenen
volk einem wahren folgt das irgendwie
unfehlbar ist und moralisch nicht so gut
wie die elite genau und im grunde ist
diese vorstellung auch nicht
falsifiziert also egal was das fortan de
facto macht die populisten finden immer
einen weg zu erklären
das ist aber letztendlich hat doch genau
so lief wie es ihrer meinung nach laufen
sollte deswegen noch mal der punkt auch
wenn sie wahlen verlieren finden sie ein
erklärungsmuster um zu sagen nein
das volk hat ja eigentlich in unserem
sinne entschieden auch wenn bei einem
referendum beispielsweise was ja auch
sehr häufig mit populisten in verbindung
gebracht wird
er ist nicht so ausgeht wie gewünscht
beispiel die volksabstimmung von viktor
orban 2016 als er sein volk gefragt hat
soll brüssel hier wie es dann so wie ist
migranten ansiedeln ohne zustimmung des
ungarischen parlaments
er bekam zwar die antwort der volt 98
prozent sagten nein das geht überhaupt
nicht aber zu wenige leute haben
teilgenommen
dann würde man ja im grunde auch sagen
moment muss eigentlich zu geben dass
procedural das nicht funktioniert hat
das ganze war ungültig war orban aber
auch völlig egal
die schweigende mehrheit ist immer für
einen da wenn man populistisch er hat
dann sofort gesagt mannheim ist doch
klar die leute zu hause geblieben sind
die waren ja auch für uns ergo
marschiere ich jetzt morgen brüssel und
sage diesen brüsseler bürokraten wo er
wie er sich ausdrücken wollte den
liberalen nicht listen die angeblich
europa bestimmen das zum ersten mal das
volk gegen diese ganze ihre
flüchtlingspolitik sich gewandt hat wenn
er wolle listen respektieren sogar die
institutionen nicht diese selber
geschafft haben selber wenn sie sogar
wenn sie selber ein referendum initiiert
und das ganze läuft nicht so wie sein
gelaufen sollte finden sie einen umweg
um zu sagen nein auf eine perverse weise
gewinnen wie immer mich interessiert
noch mal das den punkt mit den mit den
linkspopulisten was würden sie denn
sagen also jetzt wenn man in europa
in den süden blick da gibt es pro demos
in spanien und theresa in griechenland
die werden oft des linkspopulisten
bezeichnet zebras und um turin würden
sie das unterschreiben oder wer ist denn
neben java es für sie noch ein links
also da gab es sicherlich zum teil auch
andere tot die in dieses bild passt
zumal der grupo de muss man auch
explizit gesagt hat wir nehmen uns diese
sogenannte rosa welle in lateinamerika
die aufgespritzten national populismus
von chavez moralist und anderen als
vorbild wir wollen in gewisser weise die
lateinamerikaner sierung von südeuropa
ich glaube inzwischen hat er sich so
entwickelt dass podemos soweit ich es
nicht kann eine relativ normale
anführungszeichen linke partei geworden
ist wo diese art von rhetorik sehr
zurückgefahren wurde wo man auch gemerkt
hat dass vielleicht in spanien wo das
thema nation ja gesagt etwas kompliziert
ist man mit so einer national
spezifische national populistischen
strategie vielleicht nicht wirklich sehr
weit kommt also insofern denke ich ist
auch mal wichtig nicht nur diese
schnappschüsse zu haben und zu sagen ist
der jetzt oder ist ihr nicht populist
und auch immer wie bei allen politischen
phänomen zu bedenken dass sind
dynamische prozesse das sind gerade und
südeuropa wo diese parteien relativ jung
sind heterogen phänomen da gibt es immer
verschiedene stimmen
wie entwickelt sich das ist ja nicht
ausgeschlossen dass eine populistische
partei sich auch in eine perfekt
demokratische richtung entwickelt und in
dieser in dieser hinsicht sich wenn man
das so sagen darf normalisiert jetzt in
der vorbereitung hat mich interessiert
zu lesen also wenn es wenn es um diesen
volks begriff geht um diese
idealisierung dieses dieses volkes und
dieses angeblich homogenen volkes haben
sie geschrieben populismus ist immer
auch identitätspolitik und das
interessiert mich immer warum ist diese
kollektive identität denn so wichtig für
die populisten ich wurde sozusagen
populisten betreiben in der tat immer
identitätspolitik daraus folgt aber
nicht dass alle identitätspolitik
populistisch und ergo irgendwie
gefährlich ist
populisten versuchen alle politischen
fragen letztendlich auf zugehörigkeit
fragen zu reduzieren
sie versuchen auch ständig konflikte
anzuziehen und sie reden zweimal davon
wir müssen das volk verein de facto ist
aber ihr geschäftsmodell kulturkampfes
geht ständig darum leute auszuschliessen
auf der poebene der eliten wenn sie so
wollen also alle anderen wettbewerber um
die macht sind persönlich korrupt sind
echte charaktere aber auch auf der ebene
des volkes selber manche gehören gar
nicht wirklich dazu gewisse minderheiten
vielleicht und natürlich all diejenigen
die mit dem populisten punkt politisch
nicht übereinstimmen deswegen ist es
auch sehr typisch dass fragen die
vielleicht eigentlich sachfragen sind
nach infrastruktur wirtschaftsfragen
werden von populisten sehr häufig in
kulturelle fragen übersetzt also in usa
beispielsweise wird sofort gesagt nein
der worum es hier wirklich geht ist
sozusagen das hort land als ermittler
westen vielleicht das vermeintlich wahre
amerika gegen diese liberalen eliten an
den küsten und wenn man da einfach so
mitspielt dann gerät man auch leicht in
gefahr sozusagen das spiel der
populisten zu spielen weil die dann
letztendlich immer sagen es geht ja nur
darum wer gehört wirklich zum volk und
während ich und es gibt genug fragen die
man auch völlig andere weise und
verhandeln kann
ohne dieses spiel gleich mit zu spielen
was wie gesagt nicht heißen soll dass
man nicht auch über kultur reden darf
aber ich denke heute ist gerade eine
sehr starke tendenz da in europa auch zu
sagen gut vielleicht haben die leute
wären linksliberalen auch irgendwie was
falsch gemacht weil wir ja so ein
kulturkampf selber angezettelt wenn wir
angefangen haben über transgender zu
reden und violetten aussehen müssen und
vielleicht an die populisten ja recht
dass man ein bisschen das zurückfahren
müsste das halte ich für völlig verfehlt
das stimmt auch empirisch nicht also die
vorstellung es jetzt sehr plakativ zu
sagen die wahrheit die amerikanischen
arbeiter hätten schramm gewählt weil
frau clinton irgendwie zu viel von
transgender geredet hat
ist empirisch ganz sicher falsch also
insofern sollte man da sehr vorsichtig
sein mit dem mit dieser form mit dieser
vorstellung ja es stimmt schon da ist
auch im kulturcafé im gange und wir
sozusagen auf der linksliberalen seite
wir haben es irgendwie übertrieben damit
wir müssen ein bisschen weniger macher
mit minderheitenrechten oder weniger
über offene grenzen reden wobei fußnote
wenn ich darf das wirklich wiederum auch
eine sache ist wo man sehr leicht in
eine rechte falle läuft denn hier ist
niemand bekannt der politisch relevant
ist der jemals offene grenzen wurde
sogar in der politischen philosophie
sind offene grenzen eine völlige
minderheitenposition
also dass man da auch so defensiv jetzt
immer sagt auch da irgendwie übertrieben
halte ich für empirisch falsch und
normativ auch für hochproblematisch
trotzdem scheint es diese kluft zu geben
zwischen populisten die irgendwie diese
abschottung wollen oder gegen die
öffnung sind und jetzt den kosmopoliten
oder wie man den nennen möchte die für
mehr freihandel sind für mehr frei
bewegung von personen waren glückte
das ist der konflikt ist real nur der
konflikt setzt sich nicht automatisch um
im populismus gegen anti populismus oder
gar demokraten gegen antidemokraten
viele dieser dimensionen dieses
konfliktes lassen sich auch demokratisch
bearbeiten verhandeln was schon stimmt
ist dass dieser konflikt der in der tat
natürlich prominenter geworden ist in
unserer zeit eine art öffnung bietet
wiederum für populisten wo sie kommen
können und sagen ja das ist unser thema
da wir antworten wir sind dafür
zuständig zu sagen wer gehört dazu wer
gehört nicht dazu wenn unsere primären
konfliktlinie bisschen anders wäre wenn
dieser mal bio ethisch wer wann beginnt
das menschliche leben oder wenn man die
klima so genannten klimawandel die
globale erwärmung wirklich ernst nehmen
würden während populisten wahrscheinlich
auch in unseren debatten sehr viel
weniger prominent denn was würden sie
denn da sagen vielleicht das manche
experten die so viel vertrauen soll aber
jenseits dessen wäre mir zumindest nicht
deutlich was populisten ein spezifisch
aus ihrer anti pluralistischen haltung
beitragen wird
irgendwelche debatten während bei in
etwa bei im eröffnungs schließungs
konflikt da sind sie sehr schnell dabei
mit der rede von wegen ja wir haben da
die antworten wir wissen wer das war
erfolg ist und wir erzählen dass man den
leuten wo sozusagen die grenzen genau
verlaufen soll
ich habe ihnen satz gelesen von ihnen
nämlich populisten sind die erben von
karl schmidt und karl schmidt war ein
staatsrechtler und mitglied der nsdap
warum sind den populisten erben von carl
schmitt in die ferne
also bevor jetzt wieder alle schreien
dass es typisch da wird einem
vorgeworfen man sei quasi nazi war man
vielleicht populist sei möchte ich sagen
dass sie in einer spezifischen hinsicht
erben von schwitzen das ist auch jetzt
wirklich auf dem level der theorie
nämlich später in den 20er jahren schon
immer sozusagen diese dieses manöver
vorexerziert wie man den vermeintlich
wahren volkswillen das wahre folgt das
irgendwie da draußen ist auf einer arm
of oder geradezu mysteriöse art gegen
die demokratischen institutionen und
prozeduren ausspielen kann
er hat damals schon gesagt gut es gibt
sozusagen was was er nochmals als
liberale statistik diffamiert hat also
wo man dann also irgendwo rein stecken
sodass am ende gezählt das war für ihn
alles nur arithmetisch das war gar nicht
ich wahre demokratie ich wahre
demokratie ist wenn der volkswille sich
auf eine viel existenzieller weise
irgendwie da draußen äußern
zum beispiel durch akklamation und seien
in gewisser weise auch begrifflicher
taschenspielertrick war zu sagen das ist
dann auch wahre demokratische
führerschaft jemand eben damals schon
vor augen schön mussolini
der war aus seiner sicht kein diktator
sondern er war jemand der auch
demokratisch legitimiert war und
liberale machen dann halt nur diese
banalen statistischen sachen nur mit
verlaub in der demokratie haben wir
letztendlich nichts anderes als zahlen
man kann sozusagen ein mysteriöses volk
gegen diese zahlen ausspielen man kann
natürlich dass irgendwas uns klar zu
stellen
jemand der eine wahl verliert sagt
natürlich wir hatten recht die die
gewonnen haben haben unrecht also das
ist ja nicht sein ich verliere
relativismus man muss sich jetzt
sozusagen nach dem sieger rechten nur es
besteht ein unterschied zwischen jemand
der sagt gut wir haben verloren
wir probieren das nächste mal noch mal
wir versuchen die bürger davon zu
überzeugen dass wir recht haben aber wir
akzeptieren erst das waren weggelaufen
anders als jemand wie sie haben auch
selber genannt jemand wie trump der im
november 2016 gesagt hat naja ob ich
ihren wahlsieg anerkenne dass über das
sage ich ihnen dann beizeiten jeder
wusste natürlich was er wirklich sagen
wollte
es gab umfragen die gezeigt haben dass
70 prozent der tramp anhängern sagten
wenn hillary clinton die wahl gewinnt
dann muss das gefälscht gewesen sein und
so die zahl ist eine schlechte nachricht
für jede demokratie also dass so ein
tiefes misstrauen herrscht was man im
grunde sagt wir würden die legitimität
eines gewissen gewinner aus einer
gewissen gewinnerin unter keinen
umständen anerkennen
jetzt bei bei karl schmitz ist ja auch
dieser anti parlamentarismus und
eigentlich bei vielen populisten sieht
man dass auch sie haben gesagt die
kritik an den eliten an parteien
parlament am ganzen politbetrieb auch in
der wirtschaft und so weiter an der eu
an über staatlichen organisationen woher
kommt denn das und kritisieren die die
eliten um ihrer selbst willen oder
sitzen da einfach die falschen leute
haben an den stellen ich würde
vielleicht zweite unterscheiden es wird
zwar zum teil gesagt dass populisten
quasi automatisch auch gegen die idee
der repräsentation sein
das scheint mir aber eigentlich der fall
zu sein wenn sie an die macht dann
gestalten sie zwei politische systeme
zum teil sehr aggressiv sehr brutal um
wie gesehen in der türkei in ungarn
jetzt auch in polen aber sie machen im
grunde nicht schluss mit dem prinzip der
repräsentation
es ist auch nicht wahr dass sie ständig
jetzt sozusagen viel mehr direkte
demokratie in umlaufenden sie wollen im
grunde auch nicht direkte demokratie
im sinne eines ergebnisoffenen prozess
wo man mal schaut was die bürger
eigentlich wirklich denken wenn sie ein
referendum machen ist es auch wieder
dieser gedanke wir wissen im grunde
immer schon vorher was das wahre volk ja
eigentlich will die rolle des volkes ist
nicht jetzt zu debattieren und sich neue
argumente und zu hören die rolle des
volkes ist im grünen und die richtige
antwort abzuhaken und die populisten zu
bestätigen also sie sind nicht gegen die
repräsentation an sich nur solange sie
nicht an der macht sind haben wir
natürlich die falschen nämlich gruppen
repräsentanten aber sobald sie an der
macht sind dieses problem gelöst
sie sind vielleicht in gewisser weise
gegen parlamentarismus weil natürlich
parlamentarismus quasi de facto immer
pluralismus heißt wir haben ja immer
mehrere parteien wir haben immer
debatten in parlamenten und das brauchen
hatte ich in gewisser weise aus sicht
der populisten nicht denn der volkswille
der ware volkswille ist ja angeblich
immer schon völlig offensichtlich ergo
diese vermittlung über parlamente
bräuchten eigentlich nicht das ist
spannend dass sie sagen eigentlich haben
die populisten und die technokraten
eines gemeinsamen nehme ich diesen ort
die plurale die beide glauben so zu
sagen entweder die experten kennen die
richtige lösung oder das war erfolg und
das ganze ist eine spirale wie ich
gelesen habe
also ihre sicht oder vielleicht sogar
eine art teufelskreis ich denke es ist
plausibel zu sagen dass eine
technokratische haltung jetzt sehr
klischeehaft gesagt es gibt eine
rationale lösung für gewisse probleme
wenn sie anderer meinung sind hauten sie
sich in gewisser weise als irrational
browsern debatten parlament müssten das
im grunde nur abnicken
diese art von haltung eben nicht unter
umständen den weg für populisten denn
die können dann durchaus mit guten
gründen sagen moment eine demokratie
ohne wahlmöglichkeiten das kann es nicht
geben wo ist denn das volk hier
was nicht heißen soll dass populisten
jetzt sozusagen die authentischen
anwälte der demokratie prinzip sind
wenn dann die populisten reduzieren dann
sage ich nur raten wiederum moment kann
man dem volk entscheidungsmöglichkeiten
gibt schaut mal was die schwere
demagogen an die macht bringen also ergo
idealerweise entziehen wird dem volk
noch mehr entscheidungsmöglichkeiten war
für populismus befeuert genau und dann
geht dreht sich das immer so schön kreis
und obwohl es dann so aussieht als
stünden sich jetzt mal extreme
gegensätze gegenüber haben sie in der
tat letztlich etwas gemein
sie sind nämlich beide form von anti
pluralismus wie gesagt bei den
technokraten es gibt nur eine rationale
lösung bei den populisten es gibt nur
einen authentischen volkswille nur wir
populisten kennen ihn wenn sie anderer
ansicht sind sind sie im grunde will
sich herr kaczynski ausdrücken würde ein
volksvertreter und so sagt stehen sich
letztendlich zwei diskurse der
alternativlosigkeit gegenüber und alles
was wir vielleicht als demokratie
verstehen würden auseinandersetzung
verschiedene optionen debatten wo bürger
auch man sich so oder so entscheiden
können alles verschwindet dann zwischen
diesen beiden extremen und wenn wir
derzeit nach italien blicken
seit seit mai diesen jahres da sitzen
alle zusammen linkspopulisten angebliche
rechtspopulisten technokraten was
verbindet dabei ist es so waren etwas
wie protest gegen das davor bestehen
das sicherlich aber protest gegen das
bestehende gibt es in italien ja seit
den frühen neunziger jahren seit das
parteiensystem der nachkriegszeit
zusammengebrochen ist ist ja jeder
angetreten mit einem hoch moralischen
diskurs ich räume jetzt auf also aus
unserer sicht kann man jetzt kann ich
mir vorstellen aber herr berlusconi trat
ursprünglich mit dem anspruch an ich
räume mit der korruption auf ich bin
gegen die parteien ich bin ganz anders
politik seines vorgängers zu sagen ich
bin jemand der von außen kommt also der
ganz grosse wellen von einem hoch
moralischen aufräumen und destruktion
discos was jetzt vielleicht wirklich neu
eine neue qualität
was man auch nicht so einfach denke ich
ein problem muss oder cezanne
vergleichen kann obwohl diese dinger
immer zusammen geworfen werden in
südeuropa ist wirklich ein radikales
experiment bei der 5 sterne bewegung die
fünf sterne bewegung basiert wirklich
auf der vorstellung dass zwei
institutionen die denke ich seit im
neunzehnten jahrhundert als eigentlich
für das funktionieren der
repräsentativen demokratie als
unabdingbar gehalten welche politische
parteien und frei professionelle medien
dass man sozusagen ist ohne die machen
kann
grillo in vielen seiner vorträge andere
ansprachen hat er immer gewinnt nicht
nur die berufspolitiker als die kaste
von korruption kritisiert und im
gleichen atemzug immer gesagt
und die berufschancen die sind genauso
schlimm leute als er damals noch bei dem
blog auch sehr aktiv war
leute ihr müsst mir direkt sagen was die
missstände sind und ich bin dann der
verstärker inzwischen haben viele leute
gemerkt dass es vielleicht nicht ganz so
simpel ist mit seinem verstärker tun
aber die suggestion war
wir können sozusagen alle vermittelnden
institutionen den parteien vermitteln ja
zwischen bürgern und dem russischen
system und medien auch wir können das
alles ausschalten und quasi eine neues
modell einführen wo alles auf ein
paradox klingt wo alles auch auf direkte
repräsentation hinaus und es ist nicht
wirklich direkte demokratie aber es gibt
sozusagen keine vermittler mehr zwischen
den bürgern und den vermeintlich einzig
legitime auch einzig moralischen auch
einzig ehrliche vertretern des
italienischen volkes nämlich den
abgeordneten der fünf sterne bewegung
und daher gibt es wiederum zu denken
dass man wie grillo auch mal sagte wir
brauchen und verdienen so was wie 100
prozent der sitze im parlament
das sagt mit verlaub normalerweise ein
demokratischer politiker eine
demokratische polizei eigentlich nicht
an interessant ist wie diese fünf sterne
bewegung mit linken ideen wie ein
grundeinkommen zusammen geht mit dieser
rechten politik eines salvini mit der
helfer sehr restriktive
migrationspolitik ist ja was zusammen
also die simple erklärung will wäre
natürlich zu sagen dass es wieder einen
fall von er ist extremst user sieht man
mal wieder
wir haben sozusagen diese liberale mitte
und die sind quasi alle irgendwie
gefährliche populisten deswegen können
die sich auch treffen das scheint mir
ein bisschen zu einfach zu sein ist ein
positiver zu sein dass man aus so
pedantisch das auch klingen mag dass man
auch hier bedenken sollte dass die fünf
sterne bewegung noch eine relativ junge
auch heterogene bewegung ist im grund
auch was neues also wenn sie vor 30
jahren gesagt hätten es könnte da
wirklich eine eine bewegung auch ein
wählerpotenzial von 20 bis 30 prozent
von leuten geben die sich so über ganz
unterschiedliche quasi anti haltungen
zusammen für
also an die große infrastrukturprojekte
auch an die impfung als total ja auch
sehr skurrile sachen was sie da denken
und die werden sich irgendwie alle dann
wieder erkennen als und zum teil linkes
zum teil aber auch ganz sicherlich nicht
linkes projekt das ist schon was neues
interessantes also da ist dann auch
diese idee die wiederum andere
theoretiker wie beispiel sogar podemos
hatten zu sagen wir müssen rechts und
links überschreiten
wir brauchen sozusagen völlig neue
koalitionen jenseits dieses alten
burschen gegensatzes die haben das
irgendwie auch geschafft also insofern
ist es nicht völlig mysteriös warum die
plötzlich auch mit rechten zusammengehen
können
sie müssen natürlich auch irgendwie
ihren anhängern erklären warum sie nicht
das gemacht haben gemacht haben was man
viel draußen so außenseiter perspektive
für plausibler und nach
demokratietheorie sich für besser
gehalten hätte nämlich eine koalition
mit den sozialdemokraten
insofern können sagt gut wie wir sagen
wir haben doch unsere glaubwürdigkeit
als gegen das alte system stehende durch
diese koalition irgendwie irgendwie
bewahren was natürlich insofern nicht
ganz stimmt ganz stimmt dass die läger
ja nun keine neue bewegung ist und die
waren ja oft genug auch schon in der
regierung haben sich herunter boss die
auch als extrem korrupt herausgestellt
also das sind zum teil sache nochmal auf
den moment was ihr da verkauft ist
eigentlich extrem unplausibel und also
gut sagt ist nicht meine aufgabe jetzt
ja fünfstern bewegung ratschläge zu
erteilen
aber so weit man sehen kann lassen sie
sich ja auch völlig gegen die wand
spielen von seoul wie in jeder ja auch
clevere weise gesagt hat ich möchte das
innenministerium dadurch beweise ich wie
sich meine zum teil ja extrem liberale
politik umsetzen lässt und es ist nicht
so einsichtig dass die fünf sterne
bewegung sich mit dieser koalition
wirklich so großen gefallen getan
über diese liberale politik möchten wir
später noch sprechen jetzt interessiert
mich noch ein bisschen auf die ursachen
zu sprechen kommen dass populismus den
wir in den letzten zwei bis fünf jahren
beobachtet haben und vielleicht davor
noch auf die wähler oder die anhänger
der populisten was weiß man da
eigentlich drüber über den bildungsstand
über überwog
über wohnort stadt land gibt es da
irgendwelche empirischen befunde wo man
sagen kann der kann man sagen solche
leute während populisten also die
populisten wirft man ja häufig vor sie
seien die großen vereinfacher aber ich
fürchte dass die beobachtete dass
populismus fällt auch die kritiker des
populismus sehr häufig eigentlich auch
das ganz gerne hätten wenn es auf genau
diese frage einfache antworten gebe und
die gibt es aber leider nicht was nicht
heißen soll dass ist alles völlig
mysteriöse ist natürlich gibt es
inzwischen genug untersuchungen die zum
beispiel zeigen dass zumindest in
manchen ländern ist schon klare muster
gibt dass die bildung mit verlaub
vielleicht nicht so groß ist gibt auch
klare muster dass in manchen ländern
ganz überwiegend männer für diese für
diese parteien für diese parteien
stimmen aber so die globale antwort die
zum beispiel denke ich viele leute auf
der linken gerne hätten wo man dann sehr
salopp der neuerscheinung mit diesem
rezept bei der hand ist wo man sagt na
ja das liegt ja nur daran dass die
sozialdemokraten oder sozialisten sich
in vielen ländern bisschen nach rechts
bewegt haben in wirtschaftspolitischen
fragen
ergo das erklärt warum in vielen ländern
die populistischen partei quasi zu den
arbeiterparteien geworden sind wir
müssen ja nur mal so ein bisschen wieder
zurück rücken und alles wird sich lösen
so simpel ist das offenbar in vieler
hinsicht nicht und die muster sind
komplizierter natürlich gibt es zum teil
auch wirklich im missstände also
populisten kritisieren heißt ja nicht
dass man deswegen verneint das was die
zum teil anprangern gar nicht dass man
das ist jetzt ihren oder dass sie sich
alles mal ausdenken und so aber die
vorstellung man könnte jetzt quasi
global sondern kleine broschüre zusammen
stellen hier wie man populisten besiegt
in drei kleinen einfachen schritten
sowas gibt es meiner ansicht nach nicht
wo liegen denn für sie die die
wesentlichen ursachen des populismus in
den usa in westeuropa also man sollte
sich denke ich schon spezifische also
man sollte ich
einzelne länder immer noch mal genau
angucken also die gründe für den
aufstieg an dass jörg haider
beispielsweise in 18 jahren sind
sicherlich andere als die für den erfolg
eines jean marie le pen sinn wiederum
andere als die für den erfolg eines
donald trump in nur zum teil ist es halt
technokratie das gefühl okay daher sind
auch immer große koalitionen am werk
andere kommen gar nicht zum zuge wie
beispielsweise in österreich eine
zeitlang die eine gewisse unsere chance
bietet für für populisten
zum teil gibt es auch mal korrupte
eliten also wenn in südeuropa gewisse
akteur sagen wie grill ja auch da ist
viel gelaufen an korruption dann ist das
jetzt im tal empirisch auch korrekt das
ist ja nicht nur das ja nicht falsch nur
weil es die populisten dann aber da
arbeiten sollten die ansprüche sind
berechtigt da gehen sie sorgsam gegen
liegen ja aber es ist der unterschied
ist halt es ist halt wie gesagt nicht
nur eine frage von inhalten also wenn er
jetzt sagen ich bin der meinung es gibt
korruption oder blasses meine haltung in
der euro krise oder hier ist meine
meinungs- anwendung könnte ich ja nicht
sagen sie sind oder sie sind nicht
populistisch sondern es kommen aber wenn
jetzt jemand auftritt und sagt wir nur
wir repräsentieren das war erfolg und
sozusagen wir verneinen die legitimität
jeder andere position
dann wäre ich wenn sie die theorie
prosieben finden dann wäre ich in der
lage zu sagen gut moment hier passiert
etwas was aus sicht auch der demokratie
gefährlich ist daraus folgt aber auch
dass man nicht sofort sagen sollte weil
diese anschlüsse an die pluralistische
sind können wir auch ganz sicher sein
dass alle wählerinnen und wähler anti
blocher listen sind das wissen wir halt
empirischen fehlender vieler hinsicht
überhaupt nicht deswegen auch ganz
deutliche warnung an diejenigen die
sagen sich diesen populisten gegenüber
sehen sich doch bitte zurückzuhalten mit
solchen verallgemeinerungen wie
seinerzeit bekanntermaßen bill clinton
als sie sagte das ist also sozusagen
hier dieser dieser basket of the proms
wir können ganz sicher sein dass die
leute auch ohne red bar moralisch
verloren sind dann begibt man sich auch
eigentlich ohne not in so eine gewisse
symmetrische position wo man sagt weil
ihr immer andere ausschließt schließen
wir jetzt auch total aus
und das ist überhaupt nicht notwendig
man kann diese akteure kritisieren oder
sozusagen sich abfällig über ihre
anhängerschaft zu äußern
denn wie gesagt im größten scheiße
wissen wäre das gar nicht so genau was
die anhängerschaft wirklich denkt und
zumindest theoretisch ist es ja auch
möglich also etwas klischeehaft beispiel
aber dass wir uns beispielsweise sagt
naja also was macht ihre band über die
anderen parteien sagt finde ich gar
nicht so interessant er glaube ich gar
nicht unbedingt aber ihre
industriepolitik das finde ich ganz ganz
toll deswegen würde ich sie wählen
das ist ja theoretisch denkbar und wenn
man dann sozusagen von vornherein sagt
nee damit auseinander setzen wir können
das quasi völlig pauschal alles ablehnen
macht man aus meiner sicht ein fehler
sie plädieren für dialog anstatt für
therapie dass man von oben herab
sozusagen die ganzen wähler hatten das
phänomen psychologisiert und dann sagt
man es auch die argumente die ansprüche
ernst nehmen und argumente austauschen
hat debattieren machen sie das
persönlich erhalten wann haben sie zum
letzten mal deinen trump wähler oder
anhänger gesprochen sie unterrichten ein
entgrenzten in den usa sie gehören
aktuell lied könnte sein weiß also man
tut was man kann sowohl auf der ebene
dieser natürlich zum teil auch elitären
elitären diskussionen diskurse aber auch
denke ich im direkten dialog mit bürgern
oder zum teil man dann auch wirklich
dinge hört die sozusagen dann auch diese
halt abfälligen äußerungen wirklich
völlig kontaktieren wo leute anhalt im
salz war der eher sagen na ja ich werde
jetzt wie in einem fall bei mir
geschehen
ich werde schon wellen weil wir es mit
den berufspolitikern probiert haben und
das ist immer schief gelaufen das war
jetzt ganz zufälligerweise ein optiker
der mir diese brille hier gemacht hat
und wenn ich clever wer hätte ich gesagt
na gut ich habe seitdem berufs optikern
probiert immer nicht ganz so ideal
gelaufen ich nehme es auch mache ich
immer von der straße mal gucken wie das
so läuft ja habe ich natürlich nicht
gemacht aber das ist man merkt natürlich
schon aber das ist auch keine besonders
profunde erkennen ist das natürlich
nicht jeder jetzt sofort mit zehn
rassistischen thesen aufwartet warum er
jump jump unterstützt und da kann man
vielleicht wenn man sich nicht um an
stellt das eine oder andere auch
ausreichen
ich denke es ist auch insofern wichtig
als das ja viele dieser traum wäre also
bei weitem nicht alle aber viele sind ja
eine situation wo ihnen wiederum von
medien also spezifisch volks und anderen
tag und nachgesagt würden ja die
liberalen legten die gucken ja auf euch
runter und das respekt für euch und so
und das sind ja meine erfahrung nach
keine direkten erfahrungen dieser bürger
die leben halt nicht hin welt wo sich
jeden tag jemand treffen der ihnen
gerade hat er keinen bildungsabschluss
ist oder du bist ja so ungebildet ist
das blöd du bist was ist das ist ein
bild was sie noch vorgegeben wird
und wenn es vielleicht ab und zu möglich
ist sozusagen dieses bild auf einen ganz
bescheidenen empirischen level zu
widerlegen durch andere erfahrung ist
dass der erste gute auf der auf der er
an ist aber auf der auf der ebene dieser
mehr offiziellen diskurs
wer mir aber auch wichtig zu sagen ich
ja natürlich
konfrontation auseinandersetzung aber
nicht sozusagen ohne bedingungen oder
nicht dazu sagen jeder kann machen was
er will
da denke ich ist glaube ich glaube ich
auch bei den berufs politikern und
politikerinnen sehr viel an urteilskraft
gefragt dass sie einerseits sichere
position begeben wo sie sagen gut wir
können über jede menge themen in einer
demokratie reden wenn sie sagen ich
möchte 0 einwanderung dann gefällt mir
das vielleicht nicht aber ich könnte
nicht sofort sagen das ist einer
demokratie nicht möglich sie sind
antidemokrat und so weiter nur wenn
beispielsweise dann in einer diskussion
ein politiker sagt es gäbe da einen
geheimen plan von frau merkel nämlich
das deutsche volk dosierer zu ersetzen
kann ist es ganz wichtig dass die
anderen teilnehmer der diskussion nicht
so tun als sei das ist auch ein beitrag
des flüchtlings politics debatte sondern
sofort die rote linie ziehen und sagen
moment jetzt machen wir noch etwas
anderes und das ist ganz wichtig dass
wir auch diese unterscheidung treffen
natürlich wird der betreffende sie
wissen dass ein real das ist ein
beispiel das denke ich mir nicht aus
also wirklich passiert natürlich wird
foul an dann nicht zurückschrecken und
sagen oh entschuldigung ja gar nicht
gemerkt dass ich da gerade eine
verschwörungstheorie lanciert haben aber
es geht ja auch gar nicht unbedingt um
ihn es geht ja er
um bürgerinnen und bürger diesen moment
ich mag ja vielleicht mit teilen dieser
dieses programms übereinstimmen
aber ich möchte vielleicht nicht
unbedingt mit leuten im boot sitzen die
ständig verschwörungstheorien notieren
die mir ständig erklären dass unsere
ganze demokratie nur noch fassade ist
dass wir sie in der späten ddr leben wo
also nur so getan wird als hätten wir
pluralismus usw
das kann ich hier auch nicht garantieren
aber ich denke das ist das beste was
unter solchen umständen andere machen
können dass sie nicht diese über
anpassungen machen dieses ja auch leider
gerade bei sogenannten mitte rechts
parteien in europa häufig heute gibt sie
das mal gesagt wir machen da so ein paar
konzessionen wir machen da so ein
bisschen mit wir haben die illusion wir
können das aber das konnte quasi
kontrollieren aber letztlich
legitimieren wir diese position diese
rhetorik sich einerseits offen auf die
diskussion auf die harte
auseinandersetzung ein lassen aber
andererseits nicht diese unnötigen
konzessionen machen und wenn es den
populisten sich sozusagen gerne
spezifisch als populisten zeigen wie im
oben genannten beispiel dann auch
wirklich sagen jetzt sind aber echt
ganze jetzt tun nicht so als sei das
eine ganz normale demokratische debatte
jetzt erscheinen ja in letzter zeit
bücher der zerfall der demokratie zum
beispiel von jascha munk dem
deutsch-amerikanischen
politikwissenschaftler wie demokratie in
sterben von stevens lewitzki den irrsee
brett und auch von der ehemaligen
us-außenministerin madeleine albright
faschismus eine warnung
irgendwie ist die demokratie von
populismus befallen hat man das gefühl
und steht vor dem vor dem abgrund und
ich möchte jetzt mit ihnen noch
anschauen was eigentlich passiert wenn
populisten dann an die macht kommen und
regieren und wir blicken dazu erstmal in
die türkei
die wo erdogan vor zwei jahren den
notstand ausgerufen hat
gewalt und einschränkungen haben die
türkei in den letzten jahren geprägt
präsident erdogan ließ nach dem
putschversuch von militärs im juli 2016
70.000 menschen einsperren hinter gitter
landeten auch beamte richter und
oppositionelle die türkei expertin
gestern bay erwartet keine abweichung
vom bisherigen kurs weil ein neues anti
terror gesetz im parlament abstimmungs
bereit ist wie in bezug auf die
grundrecht und deren einschränkung
dieser kurs wird weiter fortgesetzt
werden
es sind keine verbesserung zu erwarten
sondern im gegenteil mit dieser
gesetzgebung wird sozusagen möglich sein
gesetzt sich jede kritische stimme
mundtot zu machen und für zu verfolgen
erdogan besitzt fast uneingeschränkte
macht dank der einführung des
sogenannten präsidialsystems im letzten
april als präsident ist er neu auch
regierungschef
es gibt keinen ministerpräsidenten mehr
nun kann erdogan seine minister ernennen
ohne bestätigung durchs parlament
als präsident hat der größeres
politisches gewicht kann eigene gesetze
per dekret erlassen und die aus einem
parlament mit einem veto blockieren
und er ernennt 94 mitglieder im rat der
richter einem wichtigen justizorgane ja
ist die türkei auf dem weg in eine
diktatur
wenn ich jetzt mal ganz grundsätzlich
sagen darf es gibt ja so immer noch das
vorurteil im grunde dass populisten wie
erdogan
auch orban ungarn campen usa vielleicht
dass die eigentlich gar nicht wirklich
reagieren können waren nämlich häufig
sagt populismus um eine protestbewegung
wenn diese aktion macht sind dann können
sie ja logischerweise nicht gegen sich
selber protestieren sie können auch kein
anti elite des chors weiteren der sie
selber sind ja dann die elite geworden
oder auch eine variante dieser
letztendlich über alle vorurteile diese
politik vorstellung von den populisten
ja so hoch rennt vereinfachen
unterkomplex die werden sofort scheitern
am zweiten tag stellt sich raus das wird
gar keine mauer gebaut
es werden keine freihandelsabkommen neu
verhandelt
beispiele wie erdogan orban kaczynski
und andere zeigen uns sehr deutlich dass
es so pervers klingen mag gewisser weise
eine populistische regierungskunst gibt
wo sich die akteure zum teil auch
gegenseitig kopieren was heißt das
konkret wie man ein beispiel türkei sehr
dort nicht sehen kann
diese politiker kommen an die macht mit
dem moralischen
alleinvertretungsanspruch sie wollen im
grunde keine legitime opposition mehr
anerkennen wenn sie kritisiert werden
oder wenn ihnen auch steine in den weg
gelegt werden von unabhängigen
institutionen sein die es nun richter
seien diese nun auch journalisten
beispielsweise schießen sie immer sofort
zurück mit dem argument wir sind gewählt
hier aber nicht sie wenn sie es können
von den mehrheiten her versuchen sich
den staat quasi einzuverleiben also
alles was ein normales normales
neutrales beamten tun sein sollte wird
mit parteipolitischen akteuren ersetzen
immer mit dem argument der staat ist
doch für das volk da nur wir
repräsentieren das volk ergo ist es doch
kein problem mit den staat übernehmen
sie betreiben das was die politik
wissenschaft etwas hochgestochen massen
klientelismus nennt oder zum teil auch
etwas weniger nett gesagt form von
korruption wo man sagt nur die die uns
unterstützen wir kommen auch etwas vom
staat alle anderen können leer ausgehen
auch das kann man in der gewissen
moralischen diktion machen denn von
beginn an sind hierbei den populisten
nicht alle bürger das volk nur unsere
unterstützer sind das war volk das sie
an nichts bekommen ist völlig in ordnung
als insofern sieht man gewisse muster
die sich in all diesen fällen
wiederholen
das ist auf die bücher eingehen die sie
für ihn genannt haben das ist nicht
faschismus also erdogan ist in gewisser
weise die ausnahme er hat möchte man
sagen fast schon zu weit getrieben er
ist jetzt inzwischen so offensichtlich
repressiv das in der tat der diktatur
verdacht natürlich sehr deutlich im raum
im raum steht man ist sozusagen ein
pferd viel besser wenn man noch ein
organ sein kann
der hat nicht diese massiven
offensichtlichen
menschenrechtsverletzungen betreiben
muss und trotzdem die macht völlig
sicher wenn also 90 prozent der lokalen
medien in der hand von oligarchen sind
die der partei nahestehen wenn die
zivilgesellschaft so getriezt wird dass
viele akteure aufgeben oder sich außer
landes begeben ohne dass das so
offensichtlich ist und alle europäer am
wochenende nach budapest fahren und
sagen mensch was für eine tolle stadt
was für eine freie atmosphäre
das soll faschismus sein kann doch gar
nicht kann doch gar nicht der fall sein
also wir müssen glaube ich auch
akzeptieren dass anders als es eine
gewisse post 89 illusion uns nahegelegt
hatten nämlich dass die autoritären und
wie auch stupide sind dass sie nie was
lernen können dass die alle wieder
soweit und 1991 enden dass diese akteure
auch was lernen sie lernen auch aus dem
20 jahrhundert sie wissen genau sie
dürfen eigentlich keine bilder
produzieren die so aussehen wie das was
uns allen außer drei jahren
beispielsweise vor augen und wie gesagt
die lernformen das soll nicht heißen
dass man das jetzt unbesiegbar sind und
diese risiken da kann man gar nichts
machen
wir müssen aufgeben überhaupt nicht aber
wir haben uns vielleicht zum teil auch
ein bisschen zu leicht gemacht weil wir
gedacht haben ja irgendwann ist das so
offensichtlich wie repressiv das ist
oder irgendwann ist offensichtlich dass
es gar nicht funktioniert das irgendwie
von alleine wieder zusammen
beispiel unklar ist halt nicht und man
sagt ja ungarn seine liberale demokratie
und die these von von nachahmung den
politikwissenschaftler ist dass die der
populismus etwas hervorbringt
dass er nennt die liberale demokratie
also dieses zusammengehen von
liberalismus und demokratie das zerfällt
was wir jetzt beobachten ist entweder
eine demokratie ohne ohne rechte also
liberale demokratien oder dann rechte
ohne demokratie also einen liberalismus
ohne demokratie können sie das
verdeutlichen und und und würden sie die
diese these unterschreiben
ich kann es ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz
nachvollziehen
allein schon der ausdruck demokratie
ohne rechte leuchtet mir insofern nicht
ganz ein
als dass man in einer demokratie
eigentlich zumindest immer noch das
wahlrecht haben müsste
und wenn wir uns ein bisschen weiter und
auch plausibel fast ja auch
versammlungsfreiheit meinungsfreiheit
demokratie ist ja nicht nur dass man am
tag iks abstimmen kann sondern dass man
recht über argumente austausch also die
ganzen grundrechte die ja für die
demokratie erstens wenn dieses wort
konstitutiv sind wenn die nicht mehr da
sind dann ist das nicht nur eine
beschädigung von liberalismus sondern
eine beschädigung der demokratie an sich
und ich fürchte man läuft dann auch
wieder ein bisschen in die falle
die uns beispielsweise herr orban mit
diesem begriff die liberale demokratie
sehr bewusst gestellt hat ist ein
begriff denn wenn man wenn man sagt du
bist ein liberaler demokrat sagte ja
kein problem ich ja auch sein
der liberalismus ist für mich ja nur
homo-ehe irgendwelche spinner hatten
linksliberalen als die diskriminierungs
politik ist übrigens auch
neoliberalismus und das will ich alles
nicht sein aber vielen dank liebe leute
das eben demokratie begriff noch last
der wir nehmen wir zeigen könnte
das ist wirklich eine demokratische
substanz in ungarn geht dann hätte er
ein viel größeres problem
dann würden vielleicht auch die
bürgerinnen und bürger selber sagen
moment wir wollen doch einer demokratie
leben ist doch völlig klar
also man denke ich macht einen begriffs
fehler wenn man zumindest im kontext
dieser spezifischen beispiele sagt na ja
da gibt es halt nur leider um den
liberalismus und wenn dann auch wiederum
die europäische union unter leitung von
herrn timmermanns also unseren kommissar
für rechtsstaat sozusagen so auftritt
wie so ein liberaler der reparaturtrupp
aus brüssel deren einfliegt und sagt wir
sind jetzt hier um so ein bisschen den
rechts
hat zu retten war gab es offenbar
irgendein problem man sollte viel
deutlicher sagen nein
wenn demokratische grundrechte nicht
mehr wahrgenommen werden kann wenn es
auch keinen medien pluralismus gibt dann
ist das nicht nur ein schaden für den
liberalismus sondern für die demokratie
an sich und da sollte brüssel auch viel
deutlicher sagen wir liebe leute wir
versuchen die demokratie für euch zu
verteidigen und es geht ja nicht darum
dass wir sozusagen hier in gewinner
picken und sagen wir hätten aber lieber
persönlich an der macht natürlich nicht
aber zu sagen nein hier geht es wirklich
um die demokratische substanz an sich
was nicht heißen soll dass es keine
begrifflichen spannung zwischen
liberalismus und demokratie gibt aber in
den fällen über die wir heute reden
populisten an der macht sind
da ist die demokratie an sich gefährdet
und nicht nur der liberalismus
jetzt ist die frage was tun wir dagegen
sie nennen populismus den schatten der
repräsentativen demokratie
was müssen wir tun um diesen schatten
möglichst klein zu halten in den
nächsten jahren was muss die politik tun
das ganze wird ja zum teil so behandelt
als sei das nur so daher probleme also
wir brauchen bräuchten nur idealerweise
so einen anti populistischen machiavelli
der uns ein paar tolle strategie in
suggeriert wie wir auch rhetorisch diese
leute irgendwie in anführungszeichen
klein machen können das ist sicherlich
zu kurz gegriffen das ist nicht nur ein
pr problem
das ist auch eine frage von
substantieller politik muss ich ja weiß
es ist inzwischen ja also so etwas wie
linken populismus wir schon dann ruft
dass das vorschlägt die belgische
politikwissenschaftlerin dass man
einfach die linken ideen besser zu sagen
die leute bringt das so einfach ist es
nicht aus ihrer sicht also natürlich
sollten wenn man links ist sollte man
sagen wir müssen das irgendwie besser an
die leute bringen ist ja völlig klar
was ja sie dann auch häufig gesagt dass
wir müssen irgendwie emotionaler werden
fein kein problem ja also die emotionen
sind nicht verboten in der politik da
habe ich auch die populisten kein
monopol darauf ist es ja auch wieder
sehr nationalistisch und so von oben
herab zu halt wir machen immer die
gefühle und auch die kleinen leute die
sind ja alle so gefühls bestimmt da
kommen ja die ganzen klischees der
massenpsychologie des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts plötzlich wieder zum
vorschein wenn man im grunde sagt was
die so sagen haben gar nicht ernst
nehmen die sind ja völlig gefühllos
gesteuert weil ich für völlig falsch
diese art von dieser art von von
rhetorik jeder soll hat sich versuchen
seine sache so gut zu verkauf und nur
was ist halt die sache und man muss
hatte ich auch ein bisschen weitergehen
als wie gesagt nur diese pr ebene und
dann halt gerade fand auch bei
sozialdemokraten sozialisten fragen gut
was sie denn jetzt die idee was habt ihr
denn anzubieten was ihr besser verkaufen
wollte und wenn ihr meint dass das
irgendwie besser geht in dem ihr auch
diesen volksbefragung probiert das man
empirisch ist das nicht so
offensichtlich korrekt also ein beispiel
aus der vergangenheit
sie erinnern sich schon noch show war
sehr erfolgreich 2017 in frankreich er
hat auf seine linkspopulistischen
beraterinnen und berater gehört 2012 war
seine kampagne sehr universalistische
jeder der im mittelmeer trinkt ist
unsere sache wir sind frankreich wir
sind die universalistische nation der
menschenrechte und so weiter 2017 so gut
wie keine roten fahnenmeer nur noch
tricolor der volks zentrierte rhetorik
was ja nicht verboten ist an sich das
ergebnis nur war das ein doch sehr sehr
geringer anteil der wählerinnen und
wähler des front national zu ihm
gewechselt sind
er hat gut abgeschnitten weil das halt
so viele sozialisten gehabt die gesagt
haben und war so eine katastrophe ich
werde mir noch schon aber diese
vorstellung wir müssen sozusagen den
leuten nur mal erklären dass der
neoliberalismus der wahre feind ist
nicht die migranten also mit verlaub so
einfach ist es offenbar nicht was nicht
heißen soll dass eine wahl ist eine
theorie widerlegt das würde ich dann mit
partner also ist liege sei es geht auch
um inhalte geht nicht nur in pr
jetzt aber ganz konkret was was kann man
machen ich denke es ist relativ sicher
inzwischen dass man auf jeden fall ein
paar fallen vermeiden muss man soll
nicht in die falle laufen dass man sagt
mit denen setzen uns gar nicht
auseinander
damit tut man denen eine riesen gefallen
weil das wirklich ihr negativ gegenüber
ihren anhängern anhängern sofort
bestätigt schaut mal diese arrogante
eliten die rede noch nicht mal mit uns
die gucken auf euch hin ab es gibt diese
ganzen tabuthemen über die calle reden
darf also auseinandersetzt harte
auseinandersetzung wie vorhin
beschrieben mit den roten linien wo man
aber auch sagt wenn ihr das und das
macht dann ist sozusagen die diskussion
in dieser form auch nicht auch nicht
möglich das ist eine auf der andern
seite nicht dieses hinterher laufen also
egal wie schnell sie dann laufen und
rennen sie werden die dänische
volkspartei bei einem wohnungsbrand nie
einholen können die werden immer noch
ein paar schritte weiter seien also
nicht diese unnötigen konzession sondern
sagen wir bieten auch bewusst was
anderes klassen an illegal kontur sodass
man halt auch idealerweise wegkommt von
diesem eindruck da gibt es halt diese
schwammige quasi technokratische mitte
nein
demokratie heißt wahlmöglichkeiten klare
konturierung und die hoffnung das ist
einfach genug wählerinnen und wähler
gibt die sagen gut solange mir halt
immer dieses klar angebot macht werde
ich das auch annehmen
und anders als ja diese ganze dieses
ganze bild der vermeintlich unaufhaltsam
welle des populismus ist suggeriert sind
ja bisher auch populisten aus eigener
kraft in westeuropa nordamerika noch
nirgendwo an die macht gekommen die sind
ja nur deswegen im falle von rechts an
die macht gekommen weil vermeintliche
mainstream konservative parteien mit
ihnen zusammengearbeitet haben ihr hobby
karner mit trump beispielsweise in
österreich jetzt kurz mit der fpö also
diese diese diese vorstellung das ist
jetzt quasi unaufhaltsam sondern auch
die bevölkerungen sozusagen sind dabei
sich jetzt auch wieder in irgendeiner
autoritär richtung zufügen das stimmt ja
empirisch so überhaupt nicht
und insofern denke ich sollte man aber
auch jetzt sich in dieser auf diesen
apokalyptischen modus verfallen wo man
dann leider auch einige meiner kollegen
denke ich sehr schnellen dann auch
gerade wieder bei dieser
technokratischen rückzugs position ist
wo man sagt wir haben die wahrheit wir
sind die einzigen die rationalität
machen und wir müssen den grünen
gewissen teil der bevölkerung moralisch
und auch sonst quasi hier quasi absprung
das ist genau falsch sie sind kein alarm
ist dennoch haben sie bedenken in einem
interview mit brand eins schreiben sie
sie befürchten eine langsame und innere
erosion der demokratischen eu müssen wir
also und sorgen jaber spezifisch
spezifisch aufgrund der tatsache dass
wir hat inzwischen zwei länder in der eu
haben wo die demokratie quasi teilweise
schon abgebaut ist also ungarn und wohl
und das ist in gewisser weise viel
gravierender als die euro krise mir ist
klar dass wenn der euro auseinander
fällt das enorme konsequenzen haben
würde aber letztlich ist der euro nur
eine schlecht konstruierte politik
stellt nicht die europäische einigung an
sich in frage wenn es innerhalb von
europa starten gibt in denen es kein
rechtsstaat mehr gibt keine wirklich
freien wahlen mehr
dann steht in frage ob sich die
europäischen mitgliedsstaaten
gegenseitig vertrauen können wir haben
jetzt jüngst einen fall gehabt wo
straßburg auch gesagt hat sie können
vielleicht niemand mehr nach polen
ausliefern aufgrund ist europäischen
haftbefehls weil die gerichte dort nicht
mehr wirklich unabhängig sind und die eu
funktioniert ja vor dem aufgrund des
prinzips dass wir uns gegenseitig was im
nationalen institutionen angeht
vertrauen können
wenn das nicht mehr der fall ist dann
ist game over da gedanken das zwar nicht
so aussehen aber sozusagen der
moralischen kern ist weg und leider ist
auch unsere zeit 4 und herzlichen dank
für das interessante gespräch
[Musik]